Film Courage: Can you name a movie
that is absolutely incredible (not
Star Wars) that you’ve seen over a dozen times?
Chris Gore, Founder/Owner of
FilmThreat/Author/Filmmaker:
A movie that I’ve seen over a dozen times that is
a movie that also I come back to kind of renew my
faith in movies is Blade Runner by Ridley Scott.
The world building in Blade Runner, the sci-fi,
film noir, Harrison Ford’s performance very unlike
how we knew Harrison Ford when he played Han Solo
and I think that film has been incredibly
influential, not just with other movies
(other dystopian films) because dystopian films
of that era didn’t necessarily take themselves
too seriously, they were borderline like sci-fi
adventure comedies but Blade Runner is a classic
and it’s influential today not just in movies
but also in video games and in design. It’s funny
looking at how forward thinking Blade Runner is
in the sense that okay we don’t have flying cars
but we do have many of the things that are
in Blade Runner. Los Angeles has become very
multicultural, much more than
the time in which it was made,
so that’s a movie I can just
put on anytime and watch.
Film Courage: I think Philip K. Dick talked about
envisioning a world where the higher social strata
would live up top and as people’s income dropped,
their place in society literally dropped,
they would be living more toward the bottom.
Chris: Blade Runner in a way kind of predicted the
economic divide that we’re currently experiencing
with more and more people being pushed from
the middle class to lower middle class or
worse and a huge divide between
the elites and everybody else.
It’s unfortunate but that’s
an element of Blade Runner.
Film Courage: Can you tell us about the movies
that we want to watch over and over again versus
the movies we just want to see one time, maybe
they were satisfying enough but we're good one
and done I think that the movies that we watch
over and over again were seeking one comfort food
it's a film I'm familiar with 2001 A Space
Odyssey is a movie that I'll watch several
times a year and if it's at a retrospective
screening I'll be sitting in a perfect spot
in the theater for that movie but I think we're
seeking some kind of meaning and I will say with
the films that I do repeatedly view they're
ones that I saw probably an impressionable age
but also I'm looking at it differently so it's
interesting to see a film I saw when I was say
11 years old like Logan's Run okay and then I
see it differently now as an adult and so that's
what's that's what I find fascinating about films
that we watch on repeat or will have repeated
viewings at different phases of life because
it's in some way kind of a reflection of us
and so those films for me are movies like a
Logan's Run or a 2001 A Space Odyssey or Tron
and it's funny that those movies perhaps with
the exception of Logan's Runner still remembered
I think Logan's Run is more revered for the
performances of Michael York and Jenny Agutter
than than the actual special effects your mileage
may vary on the special effects for that film but
2001 holds up to today and I don't think that
we would have had a Star Wars or George Lucas if
Stanley Kubrick had not made 2001 because 2001
A Space Odyssey the special effects from that
film actually directly influenced George Lucas he
thought well now I can make a science fiction film
with spaceships and laser guns but I want it to
be taken seriously I don't want it to be a joke
but those those films we we revisit we're trying
to revisit I think I think it's a reflection of us
now and also revisiting perhaps who you were when
that movie made an impression so I think of myself
as a kid being dropped off at the movie theater in
Michigan by my mom to go see Logan's Run which was
PG and probably shouldn't been there's an ample
amount of nudity and deeper themes in that film
um but but that that is a film that resonates for
me today that you could hardly convince anyone
now to watch it because it definitely feels
the special effects are dated for sure but I
don't know that you'll find a better romance
in a science fiction film than Logan's Run
so I kind of I kind of revisit that film it was
seeing that by myself seeing it in a theater
a couple times after that when it came to the
dollar theater and then also kind of was my first
interest in I was a young boy I liked girls and so
that movie was a romance and so yeah it reminds me
of just being a kid and that was sort of my first
interest in girls was was seeing Logan's Run oddly
what's interesting when you when we re-watch a
movie let's say like Kramer versus Kramer which I
probably saw way too young but I thought it was
so funny but now as an adult you watch it and
it's it's very sad it's it's yeah Kramer versus
Kramer is heartbreaking it's not I mean there are
a lot of moments of levity for sure right a lot
but but there are there's so much more going on
I do think that that era in the 70s and even
like partially into the 80s was such a great
era of American filmmaking I tell people
revisit those films that was when there was
less far less Studio influence studios in fact
didn't really know what to do the marketing in
particular wasn't as sophisticated as it is now
or as controlled and I mean that in a good way
I go back and watch the original trailers for any
movie from the 70s they didn't know how to make
a movie trailer back then or at least they didn't
have the sort of very traditional kind of trailery
things that we see the the voice over the certain
certain types of musical notes and themes that
are overused quite a bit and you you could look up
videos on this there are so many so many ways that
they test these trailers because they're tracking
emotion there's certain emotions and beats that
they want to hit in addition to basically ruining
most of the movie up until potentially the third
act and if you're familiar with the genre you
can probably figure out what's going to happen
it's rare I see a trailer these days for a studio
movie that doesn't completely ruin the entire film
is that theater still there in Michigan I don't
believe it is unfortunately it was the Berkeley
Theater was turned into a drugstore but the
Berkeley Theater was walking distance or at least
bicycle distance from my house and I would go see
movies every week at that theater it was because
it was only a dollar and there was a drugstore
directly next door where I bought comic books can
you name a movie that was absolutely incredible
to watch but you've only seen it one time
yes and I'm sad to tell you it was the human
centipede there there was if anything about
the story of The Human Centipede it's absolutely
horrific and I'm not going to describe it for you
do your research at your peril but that's
a film I saw once because I had to see it
and I did review it for a a job at the time I was
doing movie reviews on on G4 TV and I had to see
the film watched it was horrified it stuck in my
mind have no interest in revisiting it and it left
quite an impression but normally movies I only see
once I only see them once for a reason and that's
because they're not very good and I don't wish to
revisit them Human Centipede I thought just the
concept of it it's it's horrifying and I guess
what what did stand out to me is that it's not
as as graphic from a horror standpoint as you
might think it's it's much more psychological
that's the type of horror film that I prefer is
a psychological horror film because I feel like
that is a movie that will stay with you that is a
movie that when you turn off the lights at night
to to to go to sleep is gonna still be in your
head and maybe you want to turn the light back
on and read a book to kind of change the change
the sort of hamster wheel spinning around in your
head about about a move and that's where I knew
a movie is is really good is when I can't stop
thinking about it most unfortunately a lot of
films that I see I'll see one time and they're
fairly forgettable they're they're sort of that
middle ground it's the ones that are really bad
or really exceptional are the ones that stand
out in my memory there's another class of movies
I think that like almost require a second
viewing in order to fully experience them
I'll give you a couple of examples the movie
memento Christopher Nolan's second feature
film starring Guy Pierce is a movie that upon
second viewing you'll you'll notice all the
details that you missed and so that one really
really left an impression on me another film I
would say Darren aronofsky's the fountain
it's not one that's brought up too often
but that film really really left an impression
upon me I think Darren Aronofsky is a brilliant
filmmaker and the fountain is another one that
I believe you can appreciate more upon second
viewing because you have things happening in
different time periods kind of that that are
reflecting or echoing each other so to speak
so I do think that in addition to movies you
may only see once I think that movies that that
require a second viewing to to gain more from
it I think are are really important to explore
what do you love about Disney Live Action remakes
uh I don't love anything about Disney
Live Action remakes I think these are
the worst films of our time that represent
everything wrong with Factory filmmaking and
Studio Executives and lawyers deciding they
need to make a movie to somehow preserve the
intellectual property and the Disney Live Action
remakes with the exception of a few I would say
the Jungle Book by John Favreau but almost
all of them have been incredibly unwatchable
thankfully the classic films on which they're
based still exist films like Pinocchio Beauty and
the Beast and whatnot but the live action remakes
have been the worst Pinocchio in particular was
one that had me specifically angry because it
was in first of all embarrassing at how bad the
film was it's everything wrong you're taking the
design of the original Pinocchio and rendering
it in computer animation and it's the exact same
design you get Tom Hanks to play Geppetto who it's
interesting in the original animation of Pinocchio
it's you you have Geppetto and he's so excited to
have a young boy a son but when you take these
Concepts and from animation 2D animation and
put them into live action there's something
about it that is at the very least unsettling
of a live-action Tom Hanks dancing with joy that
he has a young boy a young live boy that's his
I don't want to like I don't know how long
of a dramatic pause I could put there after
saying those words but there's something about
it that just seems weird in live action and I
think that that's something if you look at
animated shows like The Simpsons when they
talk about religion or politics or just so many
different issues that The Simpsons touch on you
could never do that in live action you couldn't
do a live-action sitcom that discussed those ideas
I mean you used to be able to with all in the
family but the only way to tackle those ideas
unfortunately in a mainstream way is is in 2D
animation or at least you used to be able to
but the but the live-action Disney films are
just a travesty and sort of represent everything
wrong with modern movies today everything wrong
just the updating it for modern audiences with
unnecessary gender and race swaps that I
think that audiences are beginning to Tire of
the live action doesn't really work there's
certain Concepts and ideas that work best in
animation perhaps that's why perhaps that's why
the Jungle Book is probably the one that stands
out as it is the most watchable and probably the
best of them is because it's it's all animated
it's all animated with the exception of the young
boy but but my God these these Disney animated
or these Disney Animation translations to live
action are are travesty I feel like I could teach
a class where we just watch parts of Pinocchio
daily and I tell you why this isn't working
there's even a scene in which Pinocchio trips
over a pile of feces covered in flies and
part of me thinks that the reason that the
feces in Pinocchio with the the Flies you
could hear the Flies is so graphic it was like the
animators put that in to let us know yeah we know
we know too they are this bad
and that film just it just it's it's horrific
I really get the sense that it's it's
an attorney is saying look we need to remake
these and we need to brand them to remind people
it's it's somewhat similar to there was a trend
in the 90s to do sequels to classic Disney
animated films Cinderella to Lion King 2 Bambi
to and you can probably find them at yard sales
in the clamshell VHS casing you can find the
sequels to all the classic Disney animated
features and they're all completely forgettable
and I wish they never existed and I would say
the same for all of these Disney Live Action
films is literally an attorney saying well
just do it I am I it's disappointing to see people
like Robert zemeckis who made a short on a short
list of perfect films Made Back to the Future
right and then to see Tom Hanks probably the most
beloved actor you could still call him a star for
them to team up with Disney to make it is horrific
and I just hope that Disney stops not to get too
graphic but I am curious with the pile of feces
and the Flies what in what context was that
in the scene well Pinocchio is skipping his
way to school he's distracted and happens upon
a pile of feces it's a completely unnecessary
thing to happen in the midst of the
live-action remake of the classic
Pinocchio to put in this pile of feces but I do
believe that that was a not so secret message
that the animators may have just decided to add
why would they do this otherwise there's there's
no point in it does it pay off later in the
story is it on his shoe and he says I I don't
I don't recall that it that it pays off or has
meaning but the pile of feces in the live-action
Pinocchio is the most likable character oh okay
great I say I say that with a straight face
I have some numbers here Lion King 1.6 billion
dollars worldwide Beauty and the Beast 1.2 billion
Aladdin over a billion World worldwide and The
Jungle Book almost a billion so what about the
fact that many of these remakes are huge business
you talk about a lawyer that could be sitting
behind their thing their computer figuring
out numbers yeah doesn't it make sense though
sure it makes Financial sense to remake classic
and familiar intellectual property in to another
form from live action to or from animation to live
action that makes total sense on paper I think
these films are completely creatively bankrupt and
forgettable and it's unfortunate that audiences
would not be more discriminating when
it comes to these comes to these movies
so I just don't think that we're going to
be talking about any of these live-action
Disney remakes far into the future will still
be discussing the classic films upon upon
which they're based and now forgive me I'm not a
parent but I know that moms need a break dads need
a break is this the kind of movie that hey guys
we're gonna get in the car and go see a movie what
are we going to see Pinocchio there there is there
is definitely a school of thought that will that
will say that the reason that these movies are
profitable is they're effectively babysitters so
that could could also be a reason for the
success and also I kind of find it there's
always a movie and this is in particular around
the holidays usually Thanksgiving or or Christmas
and whatnot there's a movie that offends no one
is not interesting completely forgettable but
it's the only movie the entire family can agree
that we can all go see together so that's why you
see movies opening on Christmas day right that it
is a thing a lot of movies open on Christmas Day
and not everybody wants to go see The Godfather 3
on Christmas Day but they'll go see something like
like a Disney live action remake I despise these
films with every fiber of my being so I find they
I mean I guess the best thing you can say
about them is it keeps certain artists employed
we have another quote here we've done this with
you in the past and wondering if you can read
this quote here and not sure if who it is but
let's see if I can figure it out okay I feel
like I'm on a game show now I am a filmmaker
my job is to make films when something excites
you a story or characterization you immediately
forget about everything else you only think how
to make a movie out of it the economics come only
later you shouldn't let money dictate the kind of
films you should make well I really love that
statement I'm not exactly sure who wrote it but
I love that I think well there's a couple
things it's it's an it's unfortunate that
filmmaking is the most expensive art form
even if you make a film on your iPhone at
some point you're going to have to do a
professional sound mix you're going to
have to use color correction you're going to
have to spend some money to market the film
right so even movies at a low budget level money
is sort of the unspoken producer of every movie
that's why when you see the movies with the
highest budgets many times they appeal to
everyone and no one and don't exactly leave
leave you with any sort of lasting impression
but I think money is always the unspoken
producer and in addition money is for many
beginning filmmakers an excuse to not make a movie
so I feel like you need to kind of set all those
excuses aside find out what your Baseline level
budget is to tell a story and if there's a way
to do it leap right in but now you have to tell
me who said this I don't know speaking of leap
thinking of the dancing scene that would be SS
Raj muli sorry oh wow SS Roger muli said that wow
that's fantastic he I'm I become a quick fan of ss
rajamouli he directed a film called RR which is
a Tollywood film it's it's really interesting in
India they really have competing film Industries
they have Bollywood which many people are familiar
with Bollywood and Associate most of Indian
Cinema with Bollywood but there's also Tollywood
and there I think that the rivalry between the two
industries is actually made for better films and I
will say I discovered RR when it was number three
at the box office the weekend that the Batman
opened and I found that really strange how is it
that the weekend that this biggest superhero movie
Robert Pattinson is the Batman that this movie
RRR suddenly is Unleashed in the United States
and I went to see it on a whim based on a
recommendation from a friend and noticing
like how did this film and the film just
blew my mind three-hour epic very Loosely
based on two historical figures and it has
everything Hollywood movies wish they had today
just compelling instantly likable characters
it very much felt like an old style Hollywood
movie a mix of yes there are dance numbers there's
also romance and humor action there's heroism acts
of self-sacrifice I don't know that Hollywood
can make a film like RRR and it's it's really
disappointing to me oddly enough RRR is the I
believe the highest budget movie ever to come from
India at 75 million dollars and it's it's really
quite an achievement when you see the film I would
have thought it would be it would have been in the
hundreds of millions of dollars to make this movie
but the fact that it's 75 million dollars and so
epic in scale there's a scene in at the near the
beginning of the film in the First Act character
named ROM who is an officer at an outpost
it's being protested and it's an action sequence
where ROM is sort of set on a mission to to grab
a perpetrator who threw a rock he he goes to try
to track down this perpetrator it's an epic action
scene you can't believe I mean it's just something
on a scale we've never seen I was shocked to learn
that they took almost 30 days to shoot that
scene with 20 000 extras not digital effects 20
000 extras so the achievement of this film is
so remarkable and it makes me sad that like
hey Hollywood can't compete with this and
I do see when you go to your local Cinema
wherever your local movie theater is you're seeing
more and more not necessarily your Hollywood movie
but anime you're seeing Spanish language films
Indian films I mean at the AMC theaters that I
go to in Southern California there is at least a
new Indian movie every month sometimes two a month
I personally love that because I've always enjoyed
World Cinema has I've always enjoyed it but this
film is something special one interesting
thing that I would point out about RR
is Americans reaction to this movie everyone I
know that has seen it has really loved it but
what I find interesting is we live at a time
where politics is infused into nearly every
art form comic books writing movies
television it's I could use a break frankly
from being lectured to no one likes to be
lectured to and this film does not do that
but there are thematically some interesting
things that are opposing in it and I'm really
surprised that that I've never seen anyone
point this out about RR on the one hand
the villains of the film are
the colonizers the British
the Sun never sets on the British Empire is what
they say and there's a character governor Scott in
RRR that is I mean he is a villain right out
of a Star Wars movie with the British accent
and whatnot so the white Colonial Invaders of
India are the bad people now that is a political
messaging it's also a real historical thing that
happened okay so it's not like it's a message but
that's something that would appeal
to one side of the political aisle
would be hey the colonizers are the baddies
in this movie in addition in the same movie
there is also a thread about guns and owning a
gun and the correct use of a gun responsible use
of a weapon will lead to Freedom the character ROM
who I mentioned earlier you get a flashback in the
second half of the film with young Rahm and his
father and he's teaching him about the value of a
bullet the value of a bullet being worth more than
the life of an Indian and and how that kind of
plays through he tells them the value of bullet
what it can do responsible gun use you see sort
of training an army to to basically fight their
way to freedom from the British colonizers
so on the one hand you have a movie
that's very anti-colonizer that is
also very pro-second Amendment you could look
at it that way I don't think I've seen a movie
I can't even think of a film that contains if
you've seen the movie RR as many times as I
have you'll notice it two opposing sides of the
political aisle in terms of messaging one being
anti-colonizer another one being pro-gun I don't
know that SS Raja Mali intended it to be that way
I don't believe he's lecturing in any portion
of the film at all I think it's all organic to
the story I just find it fascinating that not one
person has pointed this out that's interesting I
hadn't even thought of it I'm referring back to
the scene that you're talking about and there's
also just to keep it lighter there's friendship
there's romance there's amazing dance sequences
and then there's these animals right animals all
digitally the animals are all digitally created
right but also ROM's Mission which his sort of
his family is decimated and murdered by the the
colonizers right by the British the British
soldiers wipe out his family and his tribe
nearly everyone in his tribe and then he grows
up and he's on a mission to get the guns because
guns will lead to freedom and if I mean India
was not United as a country at the time this
for a historical frame of reference the story
the story of our art takes place in the 1920s
it's also based on two real historical figures
and imagines if they had met right they never
actually didn't eat but but the film kind of is
is definitely I would call it historical fantasy
but you India was not United as a country it
was groups of tribes and the British colonizers
coming in kind of helped unite the people and
the the rahm's mission is his whole mission is
to get weapons and then deliver them to his
tribes so they can fight for their freedom
and at least fight on an even playing field with
the British having guns and them having guns so
these are sensitive things to think about and
talk about because we live at a time where even
if you reveal even a hint at what your politics
might be it could be a death sentence for a
career which is sad to me it's sad that we can't
have open and honest conversations about a whole
number of issues I would love to be able to do
that but it's funny that this wildly successful
very mainstream and entertaining almost a tip of
the hat to old Hollywood film RR has woven into it
some messages you could read read in that are
that are that are right in the middle of the
Divide of where people are right now in the
United States and are they on two different
religious spectrums as well in the film no they
don't not so much I mean the film does deal with
that but what I love about SS Raja Mali as
a filmmaker he was asked in an interview
or the interviewer asked him said hey have you
thought about doing a Marvel movie you should you
based on the action in RRR you
should be making a Marvel movie
and SS Raja Mali said I have no interest in doing
a Marvel movie I don't want to do that and he
wants to keep his focus on telling stories from
Indian history and Indian mysticism and fables and
I think that that is why I so admire Raja Mali is
a filmmaker because he wants to stick to his roots
and I think that that's incredibly admirable
did you expect to love the movie going in
I didn't know I didn't know what to expect
about RRR when I went in to see it I just
thought well okay it's three hours I
know I'm gonna have to take a break
at some point there's going to be an
intermission whether there is one or not
but I just fell in love with it because because it
reminded me of a type of movie that Hollywood used
to make which wasn't any genre you could easily
just say well RR is an action movie it's not just
that it's also a historical fantasy it's also
a love story in fact there are two love stories
maybe three if you encount if you count
the friendship between beam and ROM
so it really is in my top probably top
five if not top three movies of the year
and it should give Hollywood pause to see how
successful this film is internationally how it's
beloved by anyone that sees it if there's a way to
see RRR in a movie theater I strongly recommend it
I've seen it in the theater four times I'm
actually going to see it for a fifth time in
the theater and when you see this movie it's like
a celebration I haven't seen an audience react
this way to a film in a theater since the very
end of Avengers end game that sort of swell of
you don't want to just clap you want to stand
up and applaud you want to scream for joy
I mean I can think of times in the past
where I've screamed at a movie theater
and applauded for Joy but I haven't done
that I haven't done that with a Hollywood
film probably since that scene and end game
the portals scene which is the the very end
of the film I thought that was like that was
the combination of 10 years of Marvel movies
and telling effectively what turned out to
be one story leading to that epic battle
Nothing Compares except for the film RR and
seeing it in the theater is for me if it's
playing I'm gonna go I'm just so taken with this
film and I think there's so much there's so much
to learn from it and I really hope that Hollywood
learns the lesson of please stop the lecturing
tell audiences a story that they can be engaged
with with characters that you fall in love with
and I think I think really that formula is
fairly simple I don't I don't know where we
got to this place where we felt it necessary to
infuse all of our entertainment with with with
some sort of lecturing it's just you just don't
need it it's Tollywood you said Tollywood yes
there yeah I am still learning about all this my
understanding is they're two dominant languages in
India there's Telugu and Hindi and sometimes you
will see they'll come out in different languages
I'm not obviously I'm seeing it with the
subtitles I can't speak either language
the only words I know are not do not do which is
the dance number the dance number in the middle
of our RR we're ROM and beam do the not to not
to dance right then it turns into a dance-off
some people some friends of mine have recommended
rr2 they they kind of cringe for a minute like oh
is it's one of those Bollywood movies with
dance numbers and I correct them because I
was corrected it's Tollywood and the dance
number is a big part of the story it's a
huge part of the story so it's not just put
in there just to be in there right there's
a purpose there's a purpose for natu natu
to be in the middle of that and God I wish
I had the skills that those actors did in that
scene it's it's it's really really remarkable
so God just if I could say one thing just go see
RR in the theater if you have the opportunity
can thank me later what do you think about Amazon
shutting down reviews for rings of power wow
Amazon shutting down reviews of rings of power is
very disingenuous I am a fan of reviews on Amazon
I can't tell you how many times it's
helped me pick out the correct product
and I'm talking not about movies here I'm talking
about just product reviews it's very bizarre to
me also that even that being a Critic is such
a weird thing like we we find Critic reviews
of things useful reviews of cars reviews of
restaurants these are all useful things right
but when it comes to to movies television shows
that's where people's passions come out I think
that Amazon shutting down the reviews for rings
of power is well it's it's in their best interests
but also exposes that they're not allowing
potential fans of the show to speak their minds
I think I think it's a it's going to be a mistake
in the long run and I also think having seen the
shows or at least half of the first season at the
time of this taping it it's really the whole thing
was just ill-conceived from the beginning and the
fact that they really couldn't endear true Tolkien
fans in what they were attempting to achieve is
is really disheartening but the shutting down of
those reviews is I mean they're going to show if
they're not going to show up on Amazon they're
going to show up somewhere else they're going to
show up in a YouTube video they're going to show
up in a comment section on a YouTube video or
something else they're gonna people are going
to be able to speak their minds about how they
feel about the show if it's not on the Amazon
website it's going to be somewhere else so there's
really no way to to completely shut it down and I
think I think it shows that they're fearing the
the reviews of just regular people that want to
talk about their love or hate for the show what
is pandering to film journalists well look I could
teach a class on pandering to film journalists I
don't know why that this became a thing it it kind
of evolved but you do see in a lot of you you
see this occur a lot when it comes to marketing
when it comes to marketing a film or a television
show they'll highlight certain aspects of the show
that may not be a big aspect of the movie itself
but they'll throw in a quick line they call it
sometimes they'll be an inconsequential character
who happens to be gay they call it queerbaiting
right so you'll get like a character who happens
to be gay who is in a TV show or a movie and then
it's loudly announced that this character
is gay and look we have gay representation
but the character really is not meaningful to
the overall story so I really hate it when I
see that that Studios Pander to journalists and
what they seem to be looking for in the way in
the interest of getting like good press for a TV
show or a movie and then I feel like it backfires
because it completely misrepresents the movie and
TV show and then I do believe that it can turn off
the audience how do actors bully fans oh I find it
really sad to see actors bullying fans these days
I first of all I think it's completely unnecessary
and I think that if they've got time to
scroll through social media and Bully fans over
opinions I think that's I don't know I don't think
that's the best use of your time I think one of
the best things you can do for your mental health
is just to not be on social media unfortunately
for me I'm on social media for for work for the
most part I don't really I don't use I don't use
social media as a way to fight with strangers
and I look if I was running a studio and I hired
Talent the first thing I would do is have them
pass over give me their passwords to all their
social media accounts they would no longer have
access to them and I think kind of the less
I know about the personal life of a celebrity
the more I tend to like them so whenever I see
like an unhinged actor or celebrity go after
just someone on social media who might have rubbed
them the wrong way I just think that it's they're
they're they're usually having a bad day or
dealing with something the problem I do think
with with actors is they go through stretches
where they work very hard and then the other
eight months of the year they have nothing to do
and that time that idle time can be spent unwisely
so yeah I I'm not a fan whenever I witness that
I think it's I think it's completely unnecessary
and it's just made me think less of the the
person in question I I'll say also I do try to
when I see a movie that may have included someone
who's involved in some recent internet nonsense
I try to separate myself from that so that
I can actually enjoy the work for what it is
in particular recently there was a case with
uh I was kind of reluctant to see clerks three
I just I've always enjoyed Kevin Smith as a
filmmaker in his early days I think he was
something of a hero to a lot of people with
clerks one what he did is is amazing he made
this movie for 20 30 grand took it to Sundance
and sold it with the contract written out in a
napkin that's a true story and the fact that he
charged up credit cards and sold his comic book
collection to get the money to make the film is
is amazing it's it's like a real life fairy tale
but I think Kevin on social media has involved
himself in conversations and fights that
I just don't think he needs to what does he need
to prove it's like he's stalking his own fans he
doesn't need to do that so I so I was kind
of reluctant to see clerks three I wanted to
see it it's the third in a series of films that
I've enjoyed with characters that I've enjoyed
and I saw clerks three and he got me he got me I
mean there's things that are kind of cheesy about
it I didn't love I think at some point Kevin
might want to outgrow the potty humor but this
movie Clerks 3 is a love letter to Indie Cinema
it's sort of his version of Cinema Paradiso in a
sense and it's the best performances ever out of
Brian O'Halloran and Jeff Anderson the two actors
that play Dante and Randall at the Kwik-E-Mart
like they're the they're the clerks and you'll
it's the best acting they've ever done in their
careers and he got me Kevin Smith got me I'm
sorry to admit but it's sad because I think
that there is a huge audience of people who
used to be fans of Kevin Smith that have grown
to they've they've sort of moved away from his
work because of how he's presented himself on
social media I try to overlook those things
and I'm I'm I'm a little disappointed that I
think people are going to miss out on clerks three
because of their feelings about the
artist it's tough to do sometimes
it's really tough to do sometimes to
separate the real life person from the work
but if you can look past it for indiscretions on
social media you could you could benefit from that
kind of thinking In fairness to talent to actors
and filmmakers screenwriters fans are just as
guilty of bullying so how do fans bully artists
well I think I think I think this gets down to
the the fact that there are just so few Stars
these days and I think a star is someone who's
on a pedestal but now we have access to everybody
because everyone for the most part are someone
everyone's on social media stars are accessible
I mean I can talk to Chris Pratt if I want to
I can talk to other actors who are on social
media and I think this is diminished diminished
actors it's it's the there's really very few
people I would I would classify as a star
I would say Brad Pitt Tom Cruise
maybe Tom Hanks but they're just very few real
stars today because they become so accessible
and even their I tend to be someone that
just avoids gossip and for years I didn't
even know that Nicole Kidman was married to Tom
Cruise I learned that later I feel like if it
doesn't apply to a movie I'm gonna see I don't
really care about a celebrity's personal life
and I think ignoring it will make you enjoy
a movie much more but but it's disheartening
that this tool we're still learning how to use
this tool and misuse this tool for a long time
we didn't have seat belts and cars and for a long
time doctors recommended smoking for your health
my doctor recommends this cigarette oh there's
print ads you can find them I think we're going
to find out I think we're going to find out that
social media is worse for us than smoking and in
some cases it's like holding a loaded weapon
you could ruin your career in a tweet so it's
unfortunate we're living in this time we're social
media and so-called influencers dominate so much
I just hope that we learn to use this tool in
a better way because it it's really infected
everything it's it's affected entertainment I mean
the fact that studio marketing departments care
what a small percentage of people a Twitter
mob thinks about a movie and will thus make
changes in a movie think about that they're
making changes in a movie because a small
percentage of people on social media care about
this thing when you could just as well say
here's the work who cares don't go see it if
you think it's something you wouldn't like
so I think being beholden to the Twitter mob is
just the worst thing someone who's creative can do
so do you think someone would see more star-like
if they're not accessible because then there's
like this mystery yeah I think we've lost
the mystery of what a star is or a celebrity
we know too much about them including who they
voted for in the last election which again just
again just sort of turns up the heat on the
rhetoric it's it's really disheartening to see
so if Marilyn Monroe or Rita Hayworth had been
on Twitter and we were able to see them too just
walking to get coffee or I mean is there something
about the fact that we don't really know those
Stars personal lives that well we found it in tell
all books and things later on we got to know who's
who's with who whom right I just think it's it's
I think I think it's social media has ruined a lot
and in particular it's it's destroyed the mystery
of celebrities and stars and it's it's also now
that it's like it does affect the the content
that's made it's effect affected movies and TV
shows in ways that I don't think are positive
because you're listening to a small percentage
of the audience that may or may not be a paying
member of the audience what's the what is okay
all right here so I don't know I don't know what
I'm doing am I on a kids show what is this the
elephant in the room what's the elephant in
the room well that's what we're wondering if
you have any take on well I think the elephant
in the room is Hollywood is making movies for
the mob on social media and not for General
audiences when you look at the successes
that have been the biggest films of the year
they've all been very mainstream movies top
gun Maverick being among them right and I think
that there's a whole section of the audience that
has felt alienated by the infusion of too much
agenda and really I go to the movies to escape
I go to the movies to get involved in someone's
story and that story and that person whose story
that I'm experiencing through their eyes may not
even look like me may not be the same gender as I
am may not be the same ethnicity I don't care I
want to be involved in a human story that I can
relate to and by relate to I don't mean I need
to see someone who looks exactly like myself I
think that what needs to happen is is that the
the films that Hollywood makes should really
be reflective of the actual audience that goes
to the movies we have seen this year as we've
gotten past the before times so to speak the the
lowest box office while we've had box office hits
we have had far less tickets sold in the
United States I mean most recently by the
end of the summer and going into the fall
some of the worst weekends we've ever seen
now there'll always be a number one movie at the
box office but when compared to previous years
Hollywood has certainly not recovered I think part
of that is that the habit of going to the movies
has been lost I think that these specialness of
big tentpole Hollywood movies has been diminished
by the sh by the the shortened window hey it's
in the theaters I'll wait I'll wait and I'll see
it later on my 4K 75 inch TV what is going to
get audiences back to the box office and it's
telling stories that are more Universal and that
means getting away from lecturing and getting away
from Identity politics and really stop infusing
agenda into what should be Universal storytelling
it it's unfortunate because it used to be a
thing where we'd all go to the movies and we'd
be talking about it the next week right we would
have discussions I liked it I didn't like it my
opinion about that film is different than yours
that's fine I love love to disagree with people
about film my favorite conversations I've ever
had people I disagreed with vehemently I love
it it's the conversation is the point it's
not it's not I'm not trying to be right okay
because we all have different experiences
we experience films differently
so I'm still sitting here
with this elephant it's gonna
but I think really Hollywood needs to
get back to who is the core audience
how can we appeal to the most people
but in a way that doesn't seem pandering
and can there even be an American identity I
think this is kind of the problem right now
like we don't we we disagree on so many so many
issues that I think that's that's a difficult task
so boy the challenges are out there for Hollywood
but just get back to the core entertaining people
and is the mob quote-unquote mob
on social media the new focus group
it's unfortunate that the mob on social media is
the focus group that's being listened to I mean
focus groups can be useful right hey the
movie is 15 minutes too long we're looking
where where can we find 15 minutes to cut
out I think that the mob on social media is
very vocal but they're not your core customer
and Studios need to stop listening to the Mob
that's that's the elephant in the room stop
listening to the Mob listen to the elephant
in the room and we're not talking GoodFellas
here no yeah exactly stop listening to social
media mobs that go after people these
are people that are bored and generally
sad because they've got the time to express
whatever their horrific an annoying opinion is
get away from it stay true make make a and
make a film that that is going to move people
I really do think we're going to look back on this
era of filmmaking and think how did so many bad
movies get made and I hope that I'm there to be
able to look back and go why did they make that
Pinocchio movie with Tom Hanks and then someone's
going to say wait a sec they made a Pinocchio live
action movie with Tom Hanks oh my God I saw it
you're not going to believe it it actually exists
I'm going to name 12 Movies 12 woke movies
okay quote unquote and I'd love to hear your
reaction sure so first one Thelma and Louise
Thelma and Louise could be considered woke
having said that I don't consider that
movie in the sense of how we see woke
today because that I don't feel it's it's it
doesn't lecture I don't feel like I'm being
lectured to in that film but yeah that
that has I would say that it definitely
has Progressive messages but I wouldn't even
really necessarily put that in a woke category
for me personally I think there's a different way
that messages have been infused into Hollywood
in the past and it's very different now where
the messaging is right on the nose and you're
being told you're a bad person if you don't
actually like the movie like if you don't like
this if you don't like this movie you're racist
or if you don't like this movie you're a sexist
or how could you not like this movie because
this person made it I kind of call BS on that
so and I don't necessarily consider
it's certainly a feminist film for sure
you know I don't have a problem
with it do the right thing get out
Fruitvale Station Mad Max Fury Road Straight Out
of Compton All About Eve Mean Girls Philadelphia
Remember the Titans glory and hidden figures I
don't know that I would call those all woke films
there's certainly movies that I'll have messages
right and look Hollywood films have always been
filled with messages I think what's new today
is that the messaging is infused in a more
overt way it used to be underneath the surface
the messages used to be the subtext of the film
for example just like Dances with Wolves right
has a lot of messages in it but it's but it's it's
just right there I think that a lot of films
that are coming out now and the reason people
are reacting so poorly is that audiences are
being judged based on if they like a movie or not
you're you're free to not like film and Louise
you're free to not like do the right thing you're
free to not like those films that's perfectly
fine but it doesn't make but what I think is
interesting is they're trying to make people
out to be bad for having a different opinion
about a movie I've never seen this in my
life and I think that's that's kind of I
think that's what's turned a lot of people off to
a movie they may actually enjoy but refuse to see
there's a recent example of that the movie
The Woman King which I think the woman King
was completely misrepresented in its marketing
it was marketed to be one thing and then the
movie is is something something else there's much
more to the film and I've never seen this happen
in a time that I've been around where an audience
is being accused of being sexist or racist for not
liking a film or a particular filmmaker you're
free to not like those things and the fact that
people feel like they have to go along with sort
of the the the what they think is the majority of
people in their peer group well everyone thinks
this so I'm gonna I'm gonna also think that
and I just find that kind of weak-minded I
always like people who have different opinions
about about films but I it's unbelievable to me
that that people 's opinion can can vilify them
or make people look differently how could you
not like this how could you not not like this
this particular film or filmmaker never seen that
ever before and I and I find it kind of shocking
what I think is most disheartening is when
you see like a studio kind of use it almost
like a marketing strategy this was this was done
with Amazon and the rings of power they tried to
accuse audiences of being racist for not liking
the diverse cast and there's quite a crossover
audience between fans of Lord of the Rings and
Game of Thrones and so HBO comes out with House
of the Dragon well that's also a diverse cast and
people love that show so what is it the same fans
who were accused of being racist for not liking
the character of Reva in the Obi-Wan Kenobi series
were also the same fans who begged to please
please put Lando Calrissian in a Star Wars movie
same fans please please can you put Mace Windu
played by Samuel L Jackson please put him in the
Kenobi series you can't accuse these fans of of
of those kinds of things I think it's it's really
disingenuous on the Studio's parts and I think
what they're doing is is that they're sort of
shielding themselves from criticism by making
certain creative choices and the fans can can
like it or not like it whatever but I don't
think they're they're racist for not liking
a particular film or character some characters
resonate Lando Calrissian is a badass love him
people love the character of
Mace Windu and what's weird is
so many so many today think like well this is this
is the first time we've ever had a character of
color in a film when you look back in particular
genre Science Fiction and Fantasy has had diverse
casts from the beginning back in the 70s so this
is this is not new what's new is using it as a
piece of marketing and weaponizing IT against
audiences to me it's always a losing strategy
it's always a losing strategy to do that let
the work speak for itself if people don't like
it don't vilify your audience how often do
you watch a movie or TV show that you hate
oh I try to avoid watching movies or TV shows
that I hate right now I think the one that
I'm watching that I vehemently dislike is
the Lord of the Rings the rings of power
I mean it's but even but even then I don't really
hate the show I'm I just don't care but I feel
I feel it's important that in order to have
an opinion about something need to have seen
it there's there there is quite a contingent of
people who have lots of thoughts and opinions
about things that they know nothing about and I
believe it was Harlan Ellison who taught me that
the common phrase that you've heard everyone
has the right to their opinion is incorrect
you only have a right to your informed
opinion so generally I like to wait to see
a TV show or a movie before I form an opinion
about it there have been plenty of cases where
trailers especially these days the trailers and
marketing are deceptive they represent completely
differently what a show is going to be and I
think a lot of that is pandering to to journalists
to try to get them to think a
certain way about something but
I don't know I think when it comes to hate
watching anything for me that normally comes
comes along the lines of like reality television
which reality television is like is like it's like
potato chips not good for you they're not good
for you but I'm like that was the worst thing ever
I can't stand it this character I can't believe
that she's with him and he's with her why did they
break up and get back together and I'm going to
open up another bag of chips so I tend to not hate
watch movies but I will 100 hate watch reality
television which is its own form of Storytelling
and just to kind of give a little
background of where that came from
the the sort of competitive reality
TV shows like Survivor and whatnot
can be traced back to a documentary called
hands on a hard body which is a movie that
I believe played Sundance and it's about a Texas
truck dealership car dealership that every year
they'd have a little promotion on the radio
where they would give away a truck for free
all you had to do and they would select
people from the radio listening audience
and they would be selected as contestants where
they all they had to do was put their hands on a
truck and the last person who still has their
hands on the truck gets to keep the truck
this is a documentary film that I strongly
recommend that you seek out but it's a
documentary subject that it's got a setup it's got
a bunch of variety of characters that we meet it's
got your main conflict you've got like what the
the goal of each character is I want to get the
truck because my my old truck is not working
I got you meet all these different types of
people walks of life they do get bathroom breaks
right but you got to keep your hands on that truck
and that the success of that documentary I
believe led to these competitive reality shows
I mean it's all storytelling right I mean there
are you'll see in the credits small story producer
right on a reality show because they create these
conflicts but if I hate watch anything it's bad
reality television and I hope you'll forgive me
you're forgiven I've done the same but what is
it what what do you get from it like when it's
like you're supposed to stop doing something
but you can't what payoff do you get I guess the
payoff from hate watching Bad reality TV for me is
I wanna I wanna see I want to see a good outcome
for the people that I care about right so I want
to see the winner get the prize okay I want to see
the couple that should be together remain together
the couple that should part let them go their
separate ways so I'd like to see some sort of
positive outcome it never really goes that way but
I do find reality television reality television is
is useful it's useful in terms of being able
to identify that this is storytelling like
other storytelling forms so you can't completely
dismiss it but I only ever hate watch those shows
how much do you think hate watching
has increased in the last few years
well for me not that much I feel like my time is
is is really valuable in terms of like trying to
juggle a lot of projects I do a movie website
I have my own YouTube channel and I make make
movies on the side and I don't have a lot of time
so if I'm going to invest in something I'm hoping
for a good experience so I don't hate watch
stuff as much as I used to but if I'm gonna
hate watch anything it's usually something
where I want to completely turn my brain off
which is always going to be something from reality
TV but it's interesting that the roots of reality
TV can be traced to a little documentary from
decades ago and I think what was the Seven Up
series or something by the British director trying
to think of what yeah seven up that was where
this British director Revisited kids every seven
years just to see how they evolved and developed
not particularly a competition show per se but
an interesting kind of check-in with like well
how are they surviving why yeah don't feel bad I
got suckered into Joe Millionaire I did also oh my
God you're one of the few people who've seen that
show I had tried to get my cable shut off because
I wanted to go cold turkey I didn't want any
more distractions and then Joe Millionaire came
along and I but I didn't hate watch it I was just
intrigued by it but but I can see that there is a
trend and we see it online and it's become a new
sport to hate watch and so I just was curious why
we've tipped the scales well yeah not everything
has to be when we eat not everything has to be a
salad or stuff that's good for us you can have
a a cheeseburger from a fast food restaurant
and not everything in our media consumption has
to be a social justice documentary that's very
you're being told is very important and you feel
really good for having sat there and watched it
I'm informed I'm enlightened now so yeah you can
you can watch bad reality TV I won't judge okay
thanks well the road rules weren't wasn't bad that
was when you first kind of like set it off as well
but Road Rules and the real world MTV that was
an interesting one so yeah no all of that stuff
how do you deal with hate watching
because you have to watch so many things
but I don't like like I don't really hate
watching the sense of like I don't know what
I'm gonna see like I see a lot of Indie movies
that nobody sees see a lot of independent films
I may end up hating the movie at the end but
I'm always hopeful I'm always optimistic I'm
always optimistic and especially when it comes to
Independent films I tend to overlook flaws because
to me an independent film is like a bird with
a broken wing I want to see it flourish I want
to see it fly I want to see it go on and have its
best possible life but Independent films the deck
is always stacked against independent filmmakers
budget wise resources marketing resources
it's it's the fact that you can make anything
watchable on an indie level is remarkable to
me so I always look for that so you're not
setting out sorry to hate it no no I'm not
setting out to hate in especially an independent
film but there are independent films I've seen
that I really hated by the end oh man I'm not
going to name names but they exist quite a few
Chris why do you love Halloween oh my God first
of all Halloween is the best holiday of the year
it involves no relatives it is the stress-free
holiday I generally get my decorations on in
September Party City's always got the the costumes
out they're out in August there's no competition
Halloween is the best holiday because it's it's
such low stress in addition it is an excuse to
revisit every horror film that you love and it's
also when the studios say hey have we got some
horror films we should release them in October but
now it's like I feel like that calendar has been
pushed into September for me it's more than
a month-long celebration so I love Halloween
yeah I don't dress up as much as I used to I used
to dress up but no I the the holiday is is great
because it's sort of top of mind for everybody
of like oh yeah that's I'm gonna go see the
new whatever horror film but yeah absolutely my
favorite personal holiday what was your costume
of choice oh man let's see I once dressed as Luke
Skywalker from Return of the Jedi in high school
that was in my senior year in my junior
year I dressed as Alex from Clockwork Orange
I literally had the white jock strap on
the outside the Jack Boots the bowler hat
the the single eyelash and eyeball on my
on on the my shirt collar my anyways or
on the on the anyways it was a very accurate
costume for Clockwork or A Clockwork Orange
and no one knew who I was not one single
person in my high school knew who I was and
there were a couple teachers that looked at me
and said how do you even know that movie so yeah
um but yeah no and more recently I
dressed as like Logan from Logan's Run
but I was Logan after he went to the new you
I just think that like Halloween is not just
an opportunity to enjoy parties it's stress-free
because it doesn't involve family or travel family
and travel can be stressful During certain
holidays and it's it's just non-stop parties
and then it's also enjoying horror movies and
getting to dress up like an adult without judgment
and so what's not to love about
Halloween even theme parks make it
a month-long celebration everything from
Universal Horror Nights not scary farm
Disneyland even does their their own Halloween
events so I love Halloween you're not ever gonna
convince me and plus I it's I'll always discover
new horror films I haven't seen during Halloween
what are your top five go-to horror films oh
wow well first off Night of the Living Dead
the Original 1968 George Romero is absolutely
one of my favorites frightened me beyond belief
that one John Carpenter's The Thing horrific I
saw that when I was a teenager and it was the
last time I ever remember sleeping with
the light on because I was so terrified
the original Halloween the very first
Halloween with Jamie Lee Curtis blew my mind
I would say alien 1979 Ridley Scott original
alien is a horror film that I mean yes people
sort of put that in the science fiction category
but it that's a horror film that holds up to today
and I got I got one more choice I got one more
see now this is like a Sophie's choice of
Horror you've put me in this position uh
I'm gonna say Poltergeist because I love Lloyd
Kaufman it's weird it's more of a horror comedy
and it's it's about fast food and then honorable
mention to Evil Dead 2 and Bruce Campbell in that
movie see I got six out of it which Halloween
movies do you watch every year Night of Living
Dead I'll watch at least once a year I used to
own so Night of the Living Dead I would watch
not just once a year I used to when I was a
kid I had a Super 8 sound projector I had a
full print of Night of the Living Dead okay and
it was the way I find it found out like because
I'd only ever seen Night of the Living Dead on
some Chiller theater or late night horror host
so I'd seen it then I didn't realize the movie
was cut when I finally got the Super 8 version
all the kids in the neighborhood where I grew up
in Royal Oak Michigan we'd put a sheet on the side
of the garage and we'd get popcorn and I would
project Night of the Living Dead full unedited
there's like full frontal nudity in that movie
there's gory stuff with guts and intestines I
mean it's a graphic movie that George Romero
really made for the drive-in but at the time
when I was a kid didn't realize probably probably
an R-rated movie and only got to see it because I
had a Super 8 projector and with money I saved
for my paper route got the complete feature
but yeah that's one that I like to watch every
year is is Night of the Living Dead it's just it's
just it's so inspiring because it's such a simple
story it's low budget and most of the action I
mean everybody says the zombies are the villains
in that movie I think the zombies are a catalyst
for all the tensions between the people that are
in the bordered up house that's where the real
conflict lies and that's I think the Brilliance
of George Romero was to focus on that aspect so
that's that's a Halloween movie I watch every year
of course Halloween without watching Halloween
it's just it just doesn't feel like Halloween the
John Carpenter original with Jamie Lee Curtis is
just I mean just the sound of that score right
you just hear that score and it's fantastic
so yeah those are those are those are ones that
I revisit can you recommend any independent films
that are Halloween based indie horror films yeah
the very first Evil Dead which I think when you
watch that film what I love about watching that
movie is just what little resources Sam Raimi had
to make the first Evil Dead film he he used like
stop-motion animation a lot of other techniques
one of my favorite techniques that he used and
he used this not just for the first evil dead
but the second one as well he called it a shaky
cam and it's sort of a it's what he what he did
was he would take a camera he would mount it on
a two by four and run with it or ride a bicycle
and it's sort of a the shaky cam is a low budget
version of a Steadicam literally just took a
camera put it in the center of the board right so
it's weighted it's in the center you have like a
seesaw the center of the Seesaw is the camera and
when you run with it it gives it a smooth look so
Sam Remy used that for at least the early Evil
Dead films not sure if he used it in Evil Dead 3
but they would call it the shaky camera and I just
love that that it's like well we've got no money
we can't afford to rent a steady cam but we're
gonna just create one and they used a two by four
as a kid what was your favorite Halloween
candy that you would always go back to that
house every year well it's going to be a
tie for me it's malted milk balls because
I love the taste of malted milk and raisin heads
raisinets because it's kind of the healthy candy
I it's got chocolates but then recently I just
found out there's tons of sugar in raisins
and I was very disappointed to learn this
but I'm still I'm a raisinet's popcorn and
soda guy at the movies because of that Chris you
recently celebrated a birthday congratulations
thank you very much yeah happy belated
birthday we got you a small gift or two and
because it's your birthday we're wondering do you
have a birthday wish a birthday wish for Cinema
oh wow yeah first of all I don't love my birthday
in the sense that I'm terrible I love to give
gifts don't get me wrong I'm terrible at receiving
them so I'll do my best and thank you so much but
no I a birthday wish I wish truthfully if I have a
serious birthday wish I wish we could communicate
respectfully between each other and by that I
mean I look at the internet or I'll look at the
comments section on a YouTube video and I see
people arguing and debating and there is there
are a lot of people that are they're basically
dug in on what their view is they're trying to
convince everyone that theirs is the Right View
and they want to win and I feel like that attitude
generally doesn't lead to the result that you're
looking for I think if the result that you want
is to win someone's win the hearts and minds
of people it's never to go about it in a way
that's aggressively you're wrong and if I really
had a wish I think that we could solve many of
the bigger problems in our world if we learn to
communicate on the internet I don't know that our
brains were really wired to communicate on these
black mirrors that we all have in our pockets
we're this is all just happening too fast
social media technology all the different we've
learned to solve all sorts of problems I can have
cheeseburgers delivered to my house using a phone
and I can I can get a ride to him to a movie
theater when my car is broken down but we
hardly are able to talk to each other and I feel
like if there's one thing if this could be a true
wish I wish we could learn to communicate between
each other where we we respect each other's views
we we learn to also just this is your view
we'll we'll kind of respectfully disagree
and I don't see that happening hardly anywhere
I only really see it happening in real life
I'll see the sort of how how depressing the
internet is and then I go off and I go for a
walk in my neighborhood in Pasadena and people
are nice to each other all sorts of different
people and that would be my wish I mean I don't
think you were expecting a really serious answer
to that most people would say World Peace
since that is impossible just I do think
that at some point we'll be able to evolve
and to be able to just talk to each other
we cannot agree on things and that's okay
agree to disagree yeah and be okay with
that yeah we used to be able to do that but
suddenly agreeing to disagree it's not enough
so I hope we get to that place because I
do think that that is the pathway towards
solving real problems do you see any positive
signs in the movie industry that give you hope
the positive signs are I think when a film that
film is a hit that's unexpected I think top gun
Maverick being a hit that surprised people it's
kind of almost like it's like that movie
was made in a bubble in another period of
time or when I see like a small Indie
movie like this horror film Barbarian
that came out recently it's done very well at the
box office so I like that those are those things
kinds of things are encouraging but I would like
to see more authenticity at at the movies I think
I think that you've seen the rise of certain
YouTubers and their popularity of YouTube and
certain YouTubers is because I think what people
respond to is authenticity I feel like when you
ask me questions I feel obligated to tell you
the truth the whole truth and nothing but the
truth I know I didn't swear in a Bible I know
we're not in court but you asked me a question
I'm going to give you my honest answer for good
or bad you're gonna you're gonna hear it from
me and I think that this is the rise of YouTube
is a platform where it's not just people talking
in an authentic way I think the most popular
YouTubers the one thing they all have in
common is they're authentic they're authentic to
Their audience I think audiences can see through
inauthenticity but I'd like to see that in movies
I like to see that also in movies I'd like to see
more stories authentically told all right well
this is very cute I appreciate this oh my God who
doesn't love a delicious cupcake we weren't sure
I love cupcakes okay okay oh this is great great
great and then a wrapped gift what is this no need
to go through this much trouble but this is this
is awesome thank you totally unnecessary what is
this oh no look at that it's the classic Star Wars
figures you already have it no I don't have these
okay this is great what I know exactly they're
going on the cupcakes okay they're definitely
gonna go on the cupcakes that is awesome wow thank
you so much oh you're welcome what what I have
a new hope for this industry My Hope Is you will
take all this knowledge and you will go off and
you will create your own thing whatever that is
create do something creative every day one of
my favorite Oscar speeches ever was it was when
Steven Soderberg won the Oscar for best director
and he dedicated his Oscar for the people who do
something creative every day do something creative
every day I don't know what that is it could
be writing it could be making something some art
project could be making a movie could be something
small be creative and really to me creativity
is and being creative and the act of creation
is like therapy for the soul so I'm just gonna put
these Star Wars figures on cupcakes and eat them.